how do you feel about that influence
that you have you better be careful
we're coming for your children there
buddy about Maring Nation yes I'm going
to do I'm going you're going to resign
I'm I've been answering your question
you answer mine it's actually not my job
to answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the
[Music]
truth on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV good evening welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored I'm in Los Angeles this week
and tonight I sit down with one of the
world's great thinkers Dr Jordan
Peterson just a few weeks ago we did an
interview that proved very popular but
that was before the events of October
the 7th and on October the 7th Hass
committed of course one of the world's
worst modern Terror attacks on the
people of Israel and that day Jordan
Peterson tweeted give them hell
Netanyahu enough is enough what did he
mean by that what is enough in terms of
Israel's response does he regret
tweeting that well I asked him all these
questions in a very wide ranging new
interview and I explained to him that
I've honestly had a lot of moral
quandaries since this conflict began
since the war War started I don't know
what a proportionate response is to what
Hamas did that day I don't know if there
is such a thing as a proportionate
response to the atrocities which
unfolded on the people of Israel but I
do know that the people of Gaza the
innocent Palestinians who live in Gaza
who've been under bombardment now for
many weeks and seen thousands of
children get killed I know that they
believe they are living through hell so
tonight I sit down with Jordan Peterson
to ask him some difficult questions
about a very very difficult
issue well I'm joined Now by Dr Jordan
Peterson Jordan great to have you back
on the program a lot has happened since
you were last on just a few weeks ago I
want to start by saying that I I'm
wrestling with a lot of moral quandaries
about this war and I'm hoping that
through our conversation today we might
get to at least have some clarity about
the moral quandaries and see if we can
uh work out what we should be thinking
about this because I think it's very
complicated um and it's got to be
nuanced this conversation do you feel
any moral quandaries about
it well I don't think you can have a war
without moral quander I mean a war is
the consequence of an unsolvable moral
quander and
so it's not surprising that the
conversation surrounding the war is full
of moral quantities because if if it was
straightforward and simple and if there
was an easy path forward then there
wouldn't be a war and so I mean
I'm I can tell you what I think is going
on to the degree that you can reduce it
to something quickly explicable you know
I think Iran is
desperate because of the tenuous whole
on power that the mulas now have in Iran
given their own citizens Rebellion I
think they see the Abraham Accords which
were the most significant step forward
towards peace in the Middle East for
like 75 years they see the Abraham
Accords as an existential threat this is
a last ditch attempt by the Iranian
mulas to use the Islam against Jews
story to prop up their own dismal Reign
and so they rattled the chain of their
Hamas puppets and said provoke and they
did and their hope is that the Israeli
response will be so overwhelming that
the Arab world turns against them and
maybe even the people who might be
inclined to know be swayed by a victim
narrative in the west and that the
Abraham Accords will fall apart and and
that'll be the end of that and that
could happen and I'm hoping it won't
because I think the Abraham Accords were
you know and it it's irritating to me
for whatever you know utility that is is
that I think I know in so far as you can
know such things that Saudi Arabia would
have signed the Abraham Accords two
years ago if Biden would have moved a
little bit more forthrightly on it and I
think the reason that he didn't and the
Democrats didn't was because they didn't
want to give Trump any credit for
anything that he had attained in his
administration and I think all of that
is appalling and you know I see this
story of Muslim against Jew being put
forward in this propagandistic manner
and I think well the Muslim world has to
make a choice too because it doesn't
look to me like their proper Champions
are is the government in Iran you know
and and and it's not like the Saudis
don't have their flaws and perhaps the
rest of the Arab governmental structures
but
the the Islam World should move in the
direction of the abrahamic cours that
would great for everyone we could have a
real peace we could have something
approximating a union of the abrahamic
people and I think the Accord was named
extraordinarily well or we could have
what we've had for the last 75 years
with the Palestinians as Perpetual Canon
fer you know at the back and call of
those for whom having them be Canon fer
is useful and so yeah well there's just
moral quandaries everywhere there it's a
Minefield but that's what I think is the
the fundamental reality of the current
situation it's a propaganda war and
there's a lot at
stake on October the 7th Hamas obviously
committed a terror attack of appalling
magnitude where were you when you first
heard about it and what was your instant
feeling about
it well my instant feeling was to be
sickened by it you know it hasn't been
that long since I was in Jerusalem and
so it was a little closer to me than it
might of otherwise being um I'm also
more sensitive to any signs of
anti-Semitic catastrophe from
studying the Holocaust for the length of
time that I did and I've always regarded
Jews as the canary and the coal mine and
I think the reason that the Jews are the
Canary in the coal mine is because
they're a successful minority you know
and if if a culture can tolerate a
successful minority it's pretty damn
robust and it's not very resentful and
as soon as a culture starts to get
resentful the Jews make an easy target
because they're a minority and so that's
an easy target to begin with but then
there the minority that has the tarity
to be successful that really brings the
resentful out of the Rat holes and I've
seen arise in anti-Semitism online over
the last three years it's just stunning
to behold on the right and on the left
jointly and then well so I was sickened
by it but then I was also immediately
suspicious of Iran's role and I mean
that doesn't require any particular
perspicacity on my part I think it's
quite obvious but but I that also opens
up the The Rat's Nest of of the
maneuvering the political maneuvering
around the Abraham Accords because you
know I was very ill when the Abraham
Accords were signed and I couldn't or
hadn't paid much attention and when I
sort of recovered my ability to see
again I saw that this remarkable peace
process had taken place and I could not
understand for the life of me why it
wasn't trumpeted on the front page of
every newspaper across the world and I
also think that Trump's team should have
got a Nobel Peace Prize for it I I
cannot see how you can possibly make a
counterargument to that for all of
Trump's flaws and for his
administration's flaws this was a major
accomplishment and yet and I know the
Saudis were behind it you know they
didn't sign it but it wouldn't have gone
forward without their nod and wink and I
know I believe that if Biden would have
taken the opportunity and been a bit
magnanimous in his response to Trump
which he could have been instead of
thinking of him as Satan himself that he
could have enticed the Saudis into a
peace Accord and we wouldn't be in this
damn situation now and now we're playing
it out the hard way you know because the
Iranians could win the propaganda war
and they've got God only knows how many
agents they have in the west you know
promoting the kind of social upheaval
that we've seen on the streets in the
last few weeks and so the narrative
could go either way but I'm rooting hard
for the
for the Abraham Accord SES and I hope
they have the courage of their
convictions and I hope they can see that
their way forward is the most
appropriate way forward for the good of
the Muslim
world or what are we going to stay in
some 14th century conflict between the
fundamentalist Muslim world and and the
Jews Jesus that sounds you know we've
had enough of that haven't we you'd
think I asked Ben Shapiro what what is
the proportionate response to what
happened on October 7th and he said
there isn't one that there is no
proportionate response and there
shouldn't be uh I mean that in itself
and I asked P ramaswami uh when I
interviewed him at the weekend the same
question and he was basically inferring
the same but he also said that um you
know he would happily put the heads of
aund Hamas leaders on Stakes along the
border as a message to people uh not to
commit this act I thought that was a a
sort of medieval barbaric response to
Med medieval barbarism and that eye for
an eye tooth for tooth is not the
solution I also believe that Israel has
a fundamental right not just to defend
itself after what happened but has a
duty to protect its people and it has to
take that Duty obviously very seriously
but if your if your mission statement as
they've made clear is to eliminate Hamas
completely and Hamas live in the in Gaza
surrounded by civilians among civilians
you can only do that you can only get
rid of Hass with massive civilian
casualties and that's where I have this
moral quandry about how much is too much
well does Israel get a license to do
whatever it wants to eliminate Hamas or
should there be a limit and if so what
is that limit well I don't think Israel
will have a license to do whatever it
wants because what will happen
inevitably and I I think if I was an
Iranian propagandist I would be counting
on this let's imagine that Israel moves
against Hamas with its usual
Effectiveness and they start winning you
know in a serious way and the casualties
Mount well it's a lot easier to take a
victim appreciation stance against a
power that's clearly winning so Israel
can't win
without acing losses along the way
because the more they manifest their M
military
superiority the easier it's going to be
for those who cast the Palestinians as
victims to hold to gain the moral upper
hand and so and that doesn't mean I know
what Israel should do because I wish I
had that wisdom but what I would like to
see happen in the best of all possible
worlds perhaps would be for the the
Sines of the Abraham Accords to say to
Israel privately first we're not budging
and then
maybe and then maybe to take a foray
into the public and say that it would be
lovely to see Saudi Arabia and come out
and say you
know we're going to continue the Abraham
peace Accord
process and then Israel could say well
if the Abraham Accord holds and we have
the probability of expanding it we can
take the risk of
not being so devastating in our response
to Hamas and they could back off but
because there'd be there'd be a counter
victory in it for them and so as far
like I can't see a better pathway
forward than that and I think that's a
potentially realistic pathway especially
because that would also have the side
benefit
of not allowing Iran to
Prevail so that's that's the best I can
do on on how this might proceed in the
in the most optimistic possible way and
I don't know if that's good enough or
not on October the 7th you tweeted give
them hell Netanyahu enough is enough and
you got some blowback for that as
everybody says anything about this were
you surprised by the scale of the
blowback do you wish you'd phrase that
tweet differently do you have any
regrets about
well you know TW Twitter is a very
complicated social media platform and
it's been difficult for me to learn how
to use it wisely and I'm not alone in
that because it's difficult to be wise
on Twitter now what I'm trying to learn
is when a tweet is appropriate and when
a long form commentary is appropriate
and the rule I think is something like
the higher the stakes the more likely
that the long form commentary is
necessary and really it would have been
better had I cuz I did release a YouTube
video where I explained some of what we
already talked about my sense that yeah
yeah and that was well that was received
much better let's put it that way but it
also gave me a chance to elaborate my
argument and so what it highlighted for
me and I felt you know I
was look I wasn't I was very taken back
by what happened
in in Israel and I was also appalled
because in my estimation it was
unnecessary as I said the Abraham
Accords could have been extended earlier
and maybe this wouldn't have been
necessary um and
so I I I allowed myself to express some
sentiment at that point without
providing context and that wasn't as
good as providing the context and
so and I'm rethinking Twitter overall at
the moment about how to use it you know
Elon has taken off the character limit
and he's also made it possible to
distribute video and so it no longer has
to be a place where impulsive exchanges
can can occur rapidly and I'm trying to
reconfigure how I use it I'm much
happier with the video now you know I
was upset because I had developed
somewhat of a Muslim following um on
YouTube and I was very happy about that
a lot of of people on the Islamic side
of the world were watching my biblical
lectures for example and you know and
I've had extensive conversations with
Muslims on my YouTube channel and you
know I burnt some of that up and I'm not
sure I did that well I I would say I'm
certain I didn't do that in the most
productive Manner and
so do I regret
it it would have been better to do the
long form to to have done the long form
to begin with with you know and Twitter
invites and rewards a certain amount of
impulsivity and it
wasn't I don't know Pierce I don't know
if it's ever time for impulsive action
especially when the stakes are serious
you
know
[Applause]
[Music]
e
there's not doubt for example that what
happened October the 7th was a form of
hell for the victims uh and for their
families um there's also no doubt that
for many living in Gaza for many
innocent Palestinians it's as we know of
the 2 million or so U residents and
citizens there
they I think it's more than half are of
child age and many are very young
children and many children
are getting killed and as a father I'm
sure as like me as a father it is
utterly heartbreaking to see so many
thousands of children being killed who
have nothing obviously to do with this
uh again this this comes back to this
moral quandry I have um you know it's
interesting when you said enough is
enough in that tweet you know some
people are already saying even if
they're very sympathetic to Israel's
need to take out Hamas they're looking
at these fairly apocalyptic scenes in
Gaza and thinking enough is enough of
that you know in other words that this
the revenge is already far greater in
terms of death toll than the original
appalling Terror attacks that again is
where I have a moral quandry well the
the question is I suppose and I don't
have an answer to this is the most
effective way of com combating Hamas
military and part of the answer to that
is is the military eradication of Hamas
even possible because as I said and we
can see it unfolding in real time as
Israel is more successful militarily and
the Cales Mount the resistance to what
they're doing is going to grow yeah and
so even if they could take out Hamas
militarily which isn't obvious given its
interpenetration with the civilian
population it
all of what's going to be played out is
going to be played out on the military
front and we can see that in the rising
tide let's say of demonstrations around
the Western world and I would say those
demonstrations are likely to get larger
and more effective in precise proportion
to Israel's success on the military side
and so then I would think well is there
another way of restraining Hamas and
well that's again that brings us back to
the Abraham Accords because they were
the most promising thing that's happened
in seven decades you know and I think
it's it's easy to underestimate what a
miracle they were the people who
formulated the Abraham Accords had to
fight the state department they tried to
introduce it under Obama to begin with
right the notion was well maybe we could
we could start the peace process with
Israel without putting the Palestinians
first and that had been off the table
conceptually in the state department as
far as I've been informed forever and
and then it was proposed during the
Obama era and it was rejected and then
it was proposed during the beginning of
the Trump era and rejected but
eventually they They Carried the day and
then they did do an end run and I think
that actually put I think that was
actually good for for the typical
Palestinian because it put a tremendous
amount of pressure on the Palestinian
authorities who are basically tyrants
who are more than willing to use their
own citizens as canid fter it put a lot
of pressure on them to actually do do
something moving moving towards a
genuine peace which is why now Iran
that's why Iran is so desperate to
scuttling ACC cords I think of course
you know so I think the way through ham
Hamas all things considered in the
medium to long run is to desperately
extend the Abraham Accords as rapidly as
possible that's not a military Victory
but you know to do this from the
armchair when you look at the full
history of this conflict the seven
decades
of of conflict between Israel and and
Palestinians Jonathan Friedland is a is
a very good uh respected Jewish
journalist uh for the guardian in the UK
he wrote a very interesting column the
other day saying you know you could
argue that both sides have a just cause
here and he said that as a leading
Jewish commentator that historically
both sides have a just cause and that
it's important to remember that and
that's why passions run so high it's why
people care so much and it's why racing
to take
sides is a mistake in this conflict what
do you think of
that well I think that you know if there
wasn't a lot to be said on both sides
then the conflict wouldn't drag on
forever and be
unresolvable know I think at some point
you do something like cut the gordian
knot which I do think to some degree the
Abraham Accords had begun to do you know
I think it's I don't think Israel's
going
away but I don't think the pales pal
Palestine isn't going away either and so
those things have to be accepted I it
looks to me like they have to be
accepted as on the ground realities now
the the problem I've seen continually I
don't know is that it's been convenient
to use the Palestinians as an irritant
to Israel in the west and so the
Palestinians have been held hostage you
know the people who portray them as
innocent victims presume that the
Palestinians have been held hostage by
the Jews let's say but I would say the
Palestinians have been held hostage even
more effectively by their own leadership
and by those who are perfectly will
willing to use them as the frontman the
Expendable frontman to irritate Israel
in the west well you can't get peace
under those
circumstances you know and
so Palestine is a reality that isn't
going to go away and Israel is a reality
that isn't going to go away and the
Abraham Accords started to recognize
that and there was move in the right
direction and if that falls apart we're
going to be back to where we were yeah
15 years ago except worse the
interesting moment for me came when
Israel turned off the power and the
water um they just were able to do that
to two million people in Gaza they could
turn off the internet and it struck me
that that was a very Vivid
reminder that Israel effectively
controls Gaza it doesn't do so
politically but it does in reality and
that for many young people in Gaza they
know this and they do feel that they've
been living in a Perpetual prison camp
where their movement is controlled where
their access to basic things like water
and energy and so on is controlled uh
and that until they get the freedom that
they crave this can never get resolved
but I also understand on the other side
that the Israelis feel how can we give
freedom to a place that is run by a
terror group who are literally committed
to the eradication of not only Israel
but all Jewish
people well you laid out you laid out
what are the two sets of valid counter
claims I mean there's another
complicating Factor too you know you you
said that you you know your moral back
is up because of the
continual toll in civilians in Palestine
especially among people who let's say
weren't even born when they first came
to power and so it's very difficult to
look at that and see it as anything but
unjust but then it begs a whole other
set of questions too doesn't it it's
like well if your government is a
totalitarian band of armed criminal
thugs what responsibility do you bear
for that as as the subjected people and
you know it's not like I know the answer
to that but you know I see in my own
country in Canada that things are
slipping and sliding in all sorts of
pathological directions and people are
letting it happen and if you let that
happen long enough well things get very
very bad and they have got very very bad
in Palestine and the answer to whatever
tyranny Israel might be exerting over
the Palestinians isn't for the
Palestinians to exert even more tyranny
over themselves especially not in
concert with a third party like Iran
who's perfectly willing to sacrifice
them at any point and so now and then
that question emerges well what
responsibility do the Palestinians bear
well then I think we start to touch on
more metaphysical issues as like well
the Palestinians like all people bear
the responsibility to live in truth and
to stand up to tyranny in their in their
deeds their attention and their deeds
and their actions because if you don't
you pay for that and so do your children
right and then so do your grandchildren
so do your great-grandchildren and you
know there seems to be something unjust
in that in that why did the children
suffer and the biblical answer to that
has always been well the children suffer
for the sins of their forefathers and
you might think well it's pretty unfair
that the world is set up that way it's
like hey it might be unfair but it is
set up that way and it does beg the
question what responsibility do the
people who are living under the thumb of
totalitarians have for the fact that
they're living under the thumb of
totalitarians and the answer isn't
none
so this is why I'm a psycholog just not
a politician I would say but no I think
I think it's I think it's a really
interesting question it's also an
interesting question why why won't Arab
states around Gaza take in Palestinian
refugees I mean these are legitimate
questions right well there's a lot of
there's a lot of chain and saber
rattling about how tyrannical Israel is
and of course they're held to a very
higher moral standard but you know the
prison that is Palestine has walls on
sides that aren't Israeli so and that no
one is certainly not the progressives
will never talk about that and that's
partly because you know all the
oppressed people are equally morally
virtuous and so the fact that the Arabs
won't take in the Palestinians you can't
even bring that up because of course the
Arabs themselves are victims of Western
colonialism which is you know one of the
most absurd propositions ever set forth
by anyone about anything but you know
here we are and it is quite a miracle in
some ways that that the the
multi-dimensional fact of Palestinian
enslavement isn't discussed in a much
more forthright manner there's many
people are building the walls that that
make Palestine into whatever prison it
is and perhaps the Israelis are playing
their role but they're by no means the
only
actors we're here good morning everybody
hope you're well thanks for joining us
you're watching the independent republic
of Mike gra right here on talk TV
welcome to Friday night with Nadine here
on prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I PE Morgan uncensored in New
York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just starred
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know what I love about
all today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech writing for
Ry Su I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going
to take the side of boozed up Brits
against these pomp you mean you're not
going to support mayor Jose
L stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like those
highly paid Consultants don't really
know what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with us are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
and Facebook and X formly known as
Twitter where is our where is our
unbiased news going to come for Welcome
to the talk it's really great to be back
my Little Darlings kids think all they
have to do is stay at home be silly take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tok then
yeah problem solved there you go who's
fit as a butches do him all right but
but he's now middle class here test I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know now you're probably going to
Boop me after show
this Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for a
living got former PMS all over the joint
saying things the last few days we have
indeed yeah great first show you having
fun oh a ton of fun King PE and King CBE
I think there's only room for one king
man you know what I'm saying just cuz
they're skin folk don't mean they're kin
F when I say I am God you think I'm
joking or not you tell me I'm not joking
I'd rather do it on camera no no no no
if it's on camera we're not doing an
interview why we'll explain why how do
you feel about that influence that you
have you better be careful we're coming
for your children there buddy about
Maring Nation yes I'm going to do you're
going to resign I'm going I've been
answering your question you answer it's
actually not my job to answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the
[Music]
truth this is talk
TV let's talk about the response of
progressives and in particular what's
happening on student campuses particular
in America you know I've been stropped
by by two things one the horrifying
immediate response not just in America
but when you saw mobs in Sydney
Australia chanting gas the Jews when you
saw huge protests by the Israeli Embassy
in Kensington and West London near where
I live um all celebrating this is all
within hours of what happened on October
the 7th you saw similar scenes in
America um so the gut reaction of many
young people appeared to be to be
celebrating what had happened and we
even had some there was a Cornell uh
Professor who you know was heard in
public saying how exhilarated he was by
what happened and still hasn't been
fired um and these are people who've
driven this cancel culture for many
years now where if you use the wrong
pronoun they want you eradicated fired
shamed abused and so on um but here if
you celebrate the actions of a terrorist
organization and killing 1500 people you
actually don't lose your job students
who beamed pramas rhetoric onto the
building at George Washington University
they haven't lost their places at that
University so even for the most heinous
possible thing that you could do which
might warrant cancellation the people
who driven cancel culture spare
themselves well this shows you how
shallow the oppressor oppress oppression
oppressor narrative really is oppressed
oppressor narrative really is you know
George Orwell famously said that the
typical middle class socialists didn't
love the poor they just hated the rich
and I think the oppressor oppressed
narrative gives people moral Licence to
identify the oppressor and to hate them
resentfully with a good conscience plus
it's also extremely simple-minded you
know and this is one of the problems
with with what's being taught in
universities and even much more broadly
than that now the notion is we can view
all human social relations and the past
itself through a metam Marxist narrative
that proclaims that there are only
oppressors and victims and that all you
have to do to be moral is to be on the
side of the victim now the shadow side
of that is that once you Proclaim your
moral superiority and you're on the side
of the victim well number one you don't
have to think anymore you just have to
identify the two sets of players and
number two number two you're moral
without effort because all you have to
do is feel sorry for the victims and
then consequence number three is the
oppressor being intrinsically evil can
be the target of everything that's
resentful and bitter and absolutely
Dreadful about you now that's the
standard narrative that's being taught
on University campuses and the
Palestinians play the role of victim and
so you can't argue against the
Palestinian cause let's say if if you
were inclined to without simultaneously
having to face the weight of every
single person who's adopted the
oppressor oppressed narrative upending
that and there's no way the university
not in the not not the state they're in
now there's no way that's going to fly
and so and so we see exactly what
happened the narrative is already in
place
all oppressed people are innocent and
virtuous
victims well so then when something like
this happens and you see the Palestinian
victims rise up against their evil
Jewish overlords then it's time for
celebration you know and we forget
entirely that the evil Jewish Overlord
story was the same story that the
Germans used so successfully and we also
forget and this is very interested in
relationship to Iran I was reading a
book by Stan zag yesterday about turn of
the century Vienna just at the end of
the Austrian Hungarian Empire and the
dawning of the movements that eventually
morphed into Nazism in Germany and one
of the things vag pointed out was that
you know if you're a corrupt oppressing
psychopath who's hellbent on exploiting
the population and you want to deflect
that the Jews make a constant positive
Universal Target right because they tend
to be disproportionately successful and
you can just say well you know I'm not
the oppressor here it's those successful
Jews and that's being played out now
that's that's that's the guise that's
the disguise of leftwing anti-Semitism
we don't hate the Jews we just love
their enemies right I mean the the
anti-semitic response in the last three
weeks has been actually quite terrifying
to watch I've got Jewish friends who are
literally living in real fear now um
some of whom were in Israel at the time
and thought well the world will rally
were behind us and actually very quickly
realized that many cases that wasn't the
case in fact the complete opposite and
only saw these scenes in dagistan at the
airport with a mob literally charging
around trying to find any Jewish
passengers they could find and it was I
mean horrendous but also if you're
Jewish this is utterly terrifying and
must take you right back to Nazi Germany
World to the
Holocaust this never again it it is
beginning to happen again well I think
we could be heartened in that regard by
the counter position though too I mean I
would
say the the reasonable majority in the
western world didn't take that stance
still and quite forthrightly I mean even
my prime minister Justin Trudeau who
virtually never says a true word word in
his life or makes a he his his actions
are conc continuations of false gestures
even you know he was he came out with a
pretty forthright statement um decrying
what had happened on the Hamas side and
that has characterized the leadership of
the West in general and so I can
certainly understand why that the tiny
minority of Jews that do exist in the
world are terrified about what's
happening no it it there's there's no
reason for catastrophic alarm it's you
know what I mean it doesn't look to me
like this is going to spiral out of
control and I'm not even so certain that
in the medium to long run it's going to
be the worst possible thing because you
know too the other thing that happened
is that a lot of the false moral
disguise of the progressive types was
exposed in a radical way in the last few
weeks I mean Harvard for example just
took a beating you know I mean first of
all Harvard was ranked dead last by fire
in terms of its support for free speech
and then it was 32 different Harvard
groups came out essentially in support
of Hamas and then a whole variety of
CEOs said they wouldn't accept the
Harvard degree as a hiring criteria and
Larry Summers came out and said you know
the previous president of Harvard that
the institution had become so corrupt
that it wasn't salvageable then you know
the White House Press Secretary decried
the actions of the squad
who were supporting the Hamas protests
you know so we're seeing cracks on the
Progressive side because of this that
haven't been evident before you know and
and Biden himself came out and talked
about how important it was to push
forward with the Abraham Accords which
was something you know I wish he would
have done two years ago but better late
than never so I can understand why
there's tremendous fear and uncertainty
but I certainly wouldn't say that all
the news is
bad
[Applause]
[Music]
let's talk about social media for a
moment we there's no doubt that the kind
of tribalism that we see in modern
society fueled by social media has
probably never been worse than I've seen
it in the last three weeks a constant
barrage of often completely fake imagery
videos claims counter claims from both
sides um but it's just a barrage and
I've been really quite shocked by just
the scale of it and how little of it
appears to even have a semblance of of
truth about it what do we do what do we
do about this oh well that highlights
that highlights a a a very pronounced
danger so you know in the last 15 years
we've erected virtual perceptual systems
and and virtual systems virtual systems
of representing reality now if your
system of representing reality is not in
accord with reality you're delusional
and right technically that's what a
delusion is and you're going to run into
trouble when you try to act in your
fantasy and run into the world well
these Virtual Worlds that we've erected
on top of the real world don't run by
the same principles as the real world
and that makes them delusional and that
illusional element is affecting us very
badly in a couple of ways I just heard
Jonathan height this morning talk about
some of the re research he's reviewing
in his new book he shows very clearly
that young liberal women the probability
that young liberal woman who saturates
her life with social media has a mental
illness is more than 50% that's how bad
it's got yeah it's really bad but that's
not the only thing that's going on you
see the other thing I've been watching
and this is really quite frightening to
me is that
the problem with online one of the
problems with online communication is it
disinhibits the narcissists and the
Psychopaths and the reason for that is
that they can circumvent the normal
control systems that obtain in
face-to-face interaction yes you know
and in face to-face interaction there's
things you will not say or do because
you will be held responsible and maybe
immediately you can say whatever the
hell you want online and you can get
away with it too and maybe even be
rewarded for it and so we have so you
just think about the amount of
criminality and quasi criminality online
35% of internet traffic is pornographic
and it isn't nice guys that are running
that let's put it that way there's an
immense amount of online criminality
like most people are targeted by online
criminals on a pretty regular basis and
then we just have the run-ofthe-mill
narcissistic Psychopaths who generate
Anonymous troll demon accounts who who
are spreading misery and sadistic hate
as fast as they possibly can and there's
no barriers whatsoever to them doing
that and so then when something does
happen that's contentious let's say the
sadistic Psychopaths just make hay out
of that right they're spreading their
misery as rapidly as they possible
possibly can for the lulls and the
lulles and to Delight in other people's
suffering and the social media companies
are naive enough not to regulate that
now regulating it's difficult but but
it's a conversation we have to have par
because I think like if we let the
psychopath that's 4% of the population
whenever they get the upper hand and
that happens from time to time
Everything Burns I also think that young
young people in particular um they are
exposed to such Relentless
dopamine imagery both still pictures
videos whatever um and in particular the
last three weeks if you're a young
person with an impressionable mind and
you getting bombarded with some of the
worst imagery imaginable you know babies
dead um limbless and so on if you're
getting that on your feed all day long
which I'm seeing on mine so they must be
it can only have an incredibly damaging
effect to to I think a Young Generation
already ripped with anxiety ripped with
problems about how to deal with the real
world and I think a lot of it is they're
just seeing so much bad stuff all the
time on social media Med which when I
was young you just couldn't see it you
would not be able to access this kind of
thing you were protected in a way from
the reality of things like Warfare um
and protected from this kind of
imagery yeah well again it's it's a
problem of technological Revolution
because this new sensory system that
we've produced this new system of
perception it's a fire hose first of all
that's impossible to govern you can
never get on top of it it's it's
infinite in its scope and then it allows
the pathological and the terrible to
spread as rapidly as the beneficial and
the good and so it is overwhelming it's
not just kids that have a hard time with
that I mean it's just these Technologies
well what do we expect they're insanely
powerful and remarkable but they carry
with it the well they carry with it all
of the implications of that insane power
on the pathological side and we don't
exactly know how to deal with it we
don't know how to we haven't evolved the
social norms even that regulate online
conduct you know I mean when I block
people on Twitter let's say I have
qualms about it you know well I'm in
favor of free speech do I block trolls
online and when exactly do I block them
you know I've got
more direct about that I have a couple
of rules you know if you're anonymous if
you're anonymous and you're annoying
it's like you're done as far as I'm
concerned but but that's just the
beginnings of the evolution of anything
approximating you saying I mean I've
wrestled with that cuz I blocked I think
11,000 people or whatever it is I can't
remember what the latest tally is um I
go on little block spurges sometimes but
to me there's no contradiction between
uh believing passionately in free speech
but also allowing yourself not to have
to listen to it you don't have to listen
to what people are saying to you you you
have the right in a in a free Democratic
Society to say look you're entitled to
say whatever you want
but I don't actually have to listen to
it that's not you're not preventing them
from exercising their right to free
speech you're just saying I don't want
to hear it well that's why that's why we
have walls like that that's a good
example of the difference between the
virtual world and the real world you
have a house and it has walls and a door
and the reason for that is you don't
want a random stranger to come in and
just yell things at you whenever right
you know and so what are the walls and
the doors on social media well we have
no idea because we thought well we'll
democratize the Public Square okay so
what does that mean it means that any
narcissistic psychopath anywhere can say
whatever they want to you and everyone
you know well you know that's just not
going to work it's not going to work
there's always been criminals and quasi
criminals and troublemakers and we have
some mechanisms of regulation in the
actual world and virtually no re
mechanisms of Regulation whatsoever on
the v in the virtual world and so yeah
it's a it's a tremendous problem and it
it is also making it more and more
difficult for us to distinguish what's
real from what's not real because you
don't know when you're being played for
a what would you call masochistic Fool
by a sadistic psychopath and the answer
to that is often often yeah you know
frighteningly often and
so my sense like i' I've proposed this
before is like I don't I think social
media
um Enterprises above a certain size
should separate people with verified
identities verified by their site not
with some universal digital ID separate
them from the anonymous types like if
the anonymous types want to post no
problem but they shouldn't get to post
with the actual human
beings because there's no responsibility
you know and then you say well you know
maybe I'm a whistleblower and I'm I'm
standing for truth and I don't want to
bear an undue responsibility for telling
truth to power it's like my sense online
is for every one whistleblower who's
genuine who's Anonymous there's 999
Anonymous troll demons who are sadistic
right yeah that's not a good
ratio you interviewed uh BB Netanyahu
quite recently actually a few months ago
um a lot of pressure on him internally a
lot of criticism uh Hamas released a
video uh on Monday of some of the
hostages attacking netanyahu's
Administration for for not having a
ceasefire and so on that was clear
propaganda but it also reflects what a
lot of people in Israel feel about
Netanyahu and the catastrophic failure
of security and defense on October the
7th he's resolutely refused to accept
any responsibility or to apologize for
that do you think he
should well I I guess I wouldn't presume
to no I mean my observation about that
was that you know people said well how
could this happen how could the Israeli
defense systems be that porous and I
would say our defense systems are way
more porous than anybody would ever want
to think you know it's very very
difficult to stop people who are willing
to light themselves on fire to singe you
and any random person in a civilized
society can cause an unbelievable amount
of Mayhem and trouble and in order to
Forstall that possibility completely
which would be impossible in any case
we'd have to move towards a surveillence
state like China where we're being
monitored 100% of the time and then the
bloody cure would be worse than the
disease it doesn't surprise me that
Israel's defense was that poorest I
don't think it I don't think it cannot
be in a society that's still vaguely
free and even if you lock people down
Jesus you can still cause a lot of
trouble if you're hellbent on doing it
so does Net should Netanyahu apologize
for the failures of the Israeli defense
system in relationship to the Hamas
attack I don't know enough to say it
isn't obvious to me that it failed any
worse than you should expect a system
like that to fail when it's faced by
Psychopathic terrorists who are being
funded by outside sources who want to do
nothing else but cause misery in Mayhem
so I interviewed Netanyahu partly
because I wanted to talk to him because
I was curious and I was also an admirer
of his economic reforms the economic
reforms that I think did raise Israel to
this position of of pronounced economic
power and entrepreneurial capacity that
they now possess which also made them a
more attractive partner during the
Abraham Accords because the Israelis had
the possibility of offering to the Arabs
the sharing of their technology and
their Entre R preneurial and managerial
prowess they had something to offer
along with their you know military
strength so I thought that was all to
the good I don't know enough about
Netanyahu and about the intricacies of
Israel politics God it's hard enough
keeping track of my own country you know
to to dare to to say anything more than
that I'm glad I'm not in his shoes how
about that that's you know I can't
imagine there's anything about that
that's that's anything other than a
abysmally difficult nonstop Dr Jordan
Peterson uh what a fascinating hour
thank you very much indeed for joining
me in hey thank you it's always a
pleasure to talk to you
[Music]
pierce
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored in
New York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just stared
out
me me and you conquer time who wins you
do you know what I love about tour today
we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
the I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going to
take the side of Booz up Brits against
these pomp you mean you're not going to
support mayor Jose L
not stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
less spotted new the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like those
highly paid Consultants don't really
know what they're
doing first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with us